okay everybody come on picture your time
in front of the tree let's go oh God
just be quiet there you are okay where's
Dylan a mom oh we need somebody to take
the picture
harsh what was that don't we always have
the fire on no I'm sure we do last year
we used it to finish cooking Claire's
turkey pieces Jay go turn it on wait
wait wait wait every Everybody 12 and
under out what honey uh what's going on
Dylan's stuck in the chair
why he's dressed up as Santa he was
going to hand presents out to the kids
oh don't tell them now I want to be with
you tell us what nothing it can wait no
I can't please my organs are shutting
down okay fine
I we have an
announcement Dylan and I are having a
baby are they smiling you're
pregnant
yes and we're really happy about
it why wouldn't you
be
wow Mom it's it's a lot to process it
once
and baby
unbelievable
congratulations oh my
gosh oh God you handled that a lot
better than I did back the day oh
outside on the inside I'm you can
somebody save my life oh oh Cam grab a
foot
yep he's really wedged in there if only
we had some kind of award-winning
placenta based lubricant fine here Dylan
use a little bit of this I can't believe
a little Dylan is going to pop out of
you what would that even look
like now I
know everybody come on in for the
picture the timer this is all going to
work out right right here definitely
yeah hang on let me get my elbows
ready okay everybody's smile say baby
[Music]
baby